[Music]
a lot of shushing happening
okay
today we have a special guest in our
briefing room uh to kick off the
hispanic heritage month i have with me
today joining me is louisiana perez she
is the white house hispanic media
director just to give you a little bit
on
louisiana's background in 2020
louisiana a venezuelan immigrant became
a u.s citizen while working on the biden
campaign in florida and we are very very
lucky
to have her here in the white house
leading our efforts to reach the
hispanic community on tv radio social
media and so much more
you can't hear me
okay
hello hello
oh okay so we need to fix
hello
hello hello
[Music]
let's start from the top
all right good afternoon everybody today
we have a special guest to kick us off
for the start of the hispanic heritage
month louisiana perez is the white house
hispanic media director in 2020
louisiana a venezuelan immigrant became
a u.s citizen while working on the biden
campaign in florida and we are very very
lucky to have her here in the white
house leading our efforts to reach the
hispanic community on tv
radio social media and so much more with
that i am so excited to bring her here
to the podium all yours lucian
thank you karine gracias kareem
latinas
casablanca
thank you so much my friend and my
colleague
okay so just to do the english version
here
today marks the first day of hispanic
heritage month
when we honor the rich history and
values the hispanic community
contributes to our nation during
national hispanic heritage month we
reaffirm the diversity is one of our
country's greatest strengths the
hispanic community enriches our
neighborhoods small business small
businesses workshop media and arts we
uplift the voices and accomplishments of
the hispanic community not only during
this month but throughout the year
we also acknowledge the struggles and
injustices that they face particularly
under the previous administration's
attack against the community
when president biden took office he made
a commitment to advance opportunity and
equity for everyone in our country
including the hispanic community for the
president that promise wasn't just words
his commitment to the community was for
real action and progress thanks to
president biden we saw the biggest
one-year
drop in latina unemployment our
administration has delivered billions of
dollars in loans to hispanic small
businesses expanded the child tax credit
to provide help to millions of families
and reduce hispanic child poverty by
more than 40 percent expanded access to
quality health care to thousands of
latino families supported equity for
puerto rico hosted regional white house
latino economic initiative summits
across the country and protected and
strengthened the daca program while we
continue the fight to build a fair
humane orderly immigration system
and thanks to president biden student
loan debt relief program almost half of
latino students with federal loans will
see their debts forgiven
this evening president biden will attend
the 45th congressional hispanic caucus
institute gala to kick off the white
house celebration of hispanic heritage
month
where he will honor the contributions of
the congressional hispanic caucus and
latino leaders from across our nation
while highlighting the work the
administration is doing to create and
advance opportunities for latinos and
their families this national hispanic
heritage month we celebrate the progress
and prosperity
and we are continuing to create for
latino communities since president biden
took office and we commit to lifting up
latino families
thank you so much thank you so much
luisiana all right
okay a couple a couple more more at the
top for you all so
um
so want to turn
turn to uh the tentative agreement that
you heard the president talk about just
moments ago early uh later this this
morning
reach overnight that will keep our
railways running as you heard from
president biden this morning in the rose
garden this is a victory for our economy
and for the rail workers who work
tirelessly to deliver food medicine
clean drinking water and more to
communities across america every day
the agreement includes well-deserved pay
raises improvements in working
conditions and peace of mind on health
care costs and it's also a victory for
railway companies who will be able to
retain and recruit more workers for
their critical industry the president
thanks all parties for working hard to
get this done this would not have been
possible without the leadership of
president biden secretaries walsh buddha
judge and also vilsack and nec director
brian deese and also
his deputy uh deputy annie's nec
director celeste drake
this includes not only the marathon
meeting of almost 20 hours that started
yesterday but heard hundreds of calls
from the biden administration to the
various parties stakeholders over the
past many weeks and months the agreement
reached today aligns with president's
view that we can build a better america
by rebuilding our infrastructure and
supply chains here at home with good
paying jobs and an economy that works
for working people
this afternoon the president will also
deliver remarks at the united we stand
summit at the white house the president
is hosting today's summit to demonstrate
that hate fueled violence has no place
in our country americans of all faiths
and backgrounds have been coming
together throughout the event to say
that an attack on one group is an attack
on all of us and this morning we
announce and the president will talk
more this afternoon about it that the
administration's civic faith and private
sector groups are all taking action to
prevent and address hate motivated
violence and foster unity you will hear
president biden rally a whole of society
response to prevent respond to and
recover from hate-filled violence and to
foster national unity he believes every
american has a role to play in this
effort the summit will end by honoring a
group of unif unif uniters
people from around the country who are
leading extraordinary work in their
communities to stand together and build
bridges heal divides and stand together
against hate they represent the best of
america
looking ahead some additional details on
president's bilateral meeting that's
happening tomorrow with the south
african president tomorrow president
biden will hold south african president
rama ramaphosa at the white house
president biden looks forward to
consulting with president ramaphosa on a
range of topics including climate crisis
opportunities to increase trade and
investment to benefit both south
americans south africans pardon me and
americans and other pressing global
challenges in addition vice president
harris will host uh president republica
ramaphosa for breakfast tomorrow morning
at the naval observatory and looks
forward to discussing the u.s african
u.s south african partnership on global
health security space cooperation and
other areas of bilat engagement and
finally on friday tomorrow president
biden will hold meetings at white house
at the white house with brittany
griner's wife
sherelle greiner and paul whalen's
sister elizabeth whalen to discuss his
continuing commitment to bringing their
family members home safely
as we have said before we believe that
russia is wrongfully detaining brittany
and paul under intolerable circumstances
and as you know
we have been directly engaged with the
russian government through appropriate
channels we made a significant offer a
couple of months ago through the same
channels we use for trevor reed
we have followed up on that offer
repeatedly and will continue to pursue
every avenue to bring them home safely
with that darlene
thanks kareem on the meeting tomorrow
with the grinder and the whalen families
is there anything more you can say about
um
how we've gotten to this point where
he's actually physically going to be in
the same room with the families it's
something they've wanted for a long time
so one of the things that the president
wanted to to make clear is uh and one of
the reasons he's he is meeting with the
families is that he wanted to let them
know that they remain
front of mind and that his team is
working
on this every day on making sure that
brittany and paul return home safely
one family member was already scheduled
to be in town and the president wanted
to meet with both of the families on the
same day
thank you and on the
the migrants that have been that are
being blessed to dc and other cities
there were some that showed up at the
vp's residence earlier this morning
is the administration looking into
whether
busting migrants around the country
is legal
so let me just say a couple things about
this because uh and it's come up in the
briefing room before because this has
been happening for the past uh several
weeks
um
so as we have said repeatedly
there is uh there is a process in place
we have had a process in place there is
a legal way of doing this
and for managing migrants republican
governors interfering in that process
and using migrants as political pawns
is
shameful is reckless
and just plain wrong
and remember these are people who are
fleeing communism
who are fleeing hardship
and if these governors truly care about
border security
they should ask texas governor ted cruz
and florida senators marco rubio and
rick scott why they
voted against the president's request
for record
record funding for the department of
homeland security
so this is what they have done these
both senators senators marco rubio
senator rick scott have voted against
did not vote for
these this funding that would have
helped the department of homeland
security that is just a fact and also
the fact that that fox news and not the
department of homeland security the city
or local ngos were alerted about a plan
to leave migrants including children on
the side of a busy dc street makes clear
that this is just a cruel premeditated
political stunt this is what they are
doing and a couple more things the
migrants including children
who arrived in martha's vineyard were
misled about where they were being taken
and what would be provided when they
arrived is also deeply alarming
the children governor abbott abandoned
in martha's vineyard the children that
the that
that governor desantis abandon
as well
you know deserve better
they deserve better than being left on
the streets of dc or being left in
martha's vineyard they deserve deserve a
lot better than that and as we have done
many times in response to attempts to
create chaos and confusion by republican
governors we are working to manage the
consequences of these two stunts uh as
well and when you say there's a legal
way of doing this are you implying that
the way it's being done now is illegal
so i'll say this um
we've been asked about if we're going to
take any legal action i would refer that
to the department of justice but there
is a process there's a process of taking
in migrants there's a process that is in
place and what they are doing
is a legal stunt is a is a is a
political stunt um
and uh
and it's
it's really just disrespectful to
humanity
it is it doesn't afford them any dignity
what they're doing when you are
abandoning families uh and children
in a place where they were told they
were going to get housing in a place
where they were told they were going to
get jobs or abandoning in the dc on the
d.c streets
it is just cruel and it's not about uh
it's not about the process actually it's
about a political tool a political stunt
that they're moving forward with
on the situation along the border uh
crossings are up drownings along the
border are increasing we've been to one
time recently where the morgue is
overwhelmed by migrant deaths
are you confident and do you feel the
situation at the border is under control
are you doing enough so
what we have um
what we have been doing is is doing the
work that wasn't done by the last
administration
we are fixing a broken system it is not
like turning the light switch on it is
going to take some time but i'll say
this more individuals encountered at the
border will be removed or expelled this
year than in any previous year that is
something of the work that the dhs has
been doing and how we have been moving
forward and making sure that we're doing
our part here
we have made we have made over 3 000
arrests in the first three months of
launching an aggressive campaign to
combat the multi-billion dollar
human smuggling industry
so we have seen
the work that we have done and how it's
been effective
and again work there is a process in
place to manage migration flows that
includes expelling migrants as required
by court order under title 42
transferring them to ice custody or
monitoring migrants through the
alternatives to detention program as
they await further processing so there
is a process in place
what these republican governors are
doing again is a political they're using
people they're using desperate people
people who are trying to come here
because they're fleeing communism
themselves
as a political pawn and it's horrific
and it's shameful
the bussing aside how do you explain
this influx
well again
we we understand that we have work to do
we understand that and we have been
doing the work to do that
we have taken unprecedented action over
the past year and a half to secure our
border and rebuild a safer and orderly
process system
in the last year and a half we have
installed new water technology and set
up joint patrols in mexi mexico and
guatemala to catch more human
traffickers we have already made 3000
arrests as i just mentioned we have
secured record levels of funding for the
department of homeland security and we
have put in place dedicated immigration
judges so asylum seekers can have their
cases heard faster we ex we have
expanded labor pathways including h to
be h-2b visas so we are doing the work
uh we know that um we know that it's
going to take some time
but again we have removed more
individuals or encountered more
individuals at the border they will be
removed
or expelled this year than in any
previous year and so that is uh tells
you a little bit about the facts of what
we've been doing
okay
thanks greg and congratulations on your
uh on your new job your name you're
gonna be leaving us i guess not yet
though you've got a few more weeks in oh
boy oh gosh don't worry okay
i have a question about the meeting
tomorrow with the families of paul
william but first you just had a pretty
impassioned response to these buses of
migrants being dropped off i wonder what
was president biden's response to them i
have not spoken to him about this uh
specifically as you know he we've been
busy he's been busy uh the last several
hours uh with the rail uh with the rail
negotiations and averting
a crisis and with the work that he's
been doing in his administration so i've
not had a direct a conversation about
this specifically in these meetings
tomorrow with the families of pauline
and brittany greiner are they going to
happen simultaneously are these separate
meetings that he's having and is he
going to offer any kind of update for
them on the efforts to bring their loved
ones home so i don't have any specifics
on how the how uh how the meetings are
going to
be executed we'll have more tomorrow for
sure but wanted to let you all know that
the meetings were happening and confirm
that for for all of you
so while i would love to say that the
purpose of this meeting is to inform the
families that uh the russians have
accepted our offer and and we are
bringing their loved ones home that is
not what we're we're seeing in these
negotiations
at this time
look as we have said the russians should
accept uh our offer they should accept
our offer today
we will keep working diligently until
the day we get to share that good news
but again the president wanted to make
sure
that their families understood that they
were front of mind and that his team was
working tirelessly every day to get
brittany and paul home safely but they
shouldn't be expecting any kind of an
update and that in a substantive way on
that front here again like i said i
would love to we would love to be saying
today uh that we
have news uh about
brittany and paul coming home today
that is
unfortunately that is not where the
negotiations are at this time
again the russians should accept the
offer
that's at the table and we will
encourage them to do that thank you
and welcome back hey thanks so much um i
just wanted to follow up on the martha
vineyard markets in your situation
um is it possible to um
to i don't know i mean are there what
recourse do you have when those kind of
situations happen
so i can tell you what the
administration is doing uh so as we have
done many times in response to these
types of attempts by republican
governors
to create really what they're doing is
creating chaos and they're creating
confusion so we are working to manage
the consequences of these stunts
the administration has been in regular
touch with the cities and fema regional
administrators have been meeting with
city officials on site to coordinate
available federal support from fema and
other
federal agencies funding is also
available through fema's emergency food
and shelter program to to eligible local
governments and non-profit organizations
upon request to support humanitarian
relief for these migrants okay and then
uh just today the world bank
and then separately the imf warned about
a real risks downside risks to the
global economy
the world bank says that there's a
growing risk of the global recession
you know obviously
a lot of concern about high inflation
here in the united states and the rise
in interest rates all over
um
that is impacting
developing countries particularly can
you say at this point
whether you think a global recession can
be avoided
and what your concerns are about the
interest rate increases it realizes the
fed is independent but the consequences
of these sort of synchronized so so a
couple of things i'm not going to get
into hypotheticals i'm not going to
predict from here
especially on on something so important
as the economy i'll leave that to
the experts to do
look what we have said what the
president has said very clearly
is that
the number one economic priority is
tackling inflation
you think about just two days ago where
the president held an event on the south
lawn with thousands of supporters
thousands of of americans on the south
lawn talking about
are celebrating the inflation reduction
act
which is part of the president's plan to
do everything that he can to lower
prices and you look at that plan it's
going to lower prices health care prices
it's going to
lower medicare costs for our seniors
which is important which is a fight
that
members of congress and the president
included had been fighting decades and
decades against big farmer and the
american people won we were able to beat
wealthy special interest
and let's not forget the gas prices as
you hear us talk about
over and over the last couple weeks of
how we've seen those gas prices go down
for more than 90 days every day
during the summer summer months and it's
gone down by more than a dollar and 30
cents this is the work that the
president's going to continue to do to
make sure that we're lowering costs and
it's part of his economic plan to make
sure that we don't leave anybody behind
that we're building an economy from the
bottom up in the middle out as you've
heard him say
as well um look it it is um it is
something um as far as the the uh
interest rate and you know where the
federal reserve is is independent uh one
of one of the areas that is uh a part of
the president's plan is that uh they
have their independency and we leave
that to them
to make their decision on what what uh
fighting inflation is going to look like
what the monetary tools they're going to
use to do just that again they're
independent so we will not comment
on that
but look we also understand that uh you
know
high costs are
are really hurting families which is why
we have done the work that we have done
these past several months and uh we'll
continue to do uh continue to make sure
we uh we find ways that uh to lower
costs for families i think what i'm
asking you is what is the the impact
you're working on a domestic problem and
lowering prices here and lowering
inflation here but it's having a
profound impact on the rest of the
economy and i wonder if you're concerned
about the impact
this is all having on developing
countries i mean development is arrested
stop right now
i understand you are asking me also for
me to predict which i i can't do from
here i am not an economist so i cannot
predict for you look we're dealing with
a global challenge we have talked about
this we're dealing with the global
challenge of a once in a generation
pandemic and we're dealing with the
global challenge of a war in ukraine
that was started by the kremlin that has
hurt food prices that has hurt oil
prices which is why we have done the
work uh that uh we have done to lower
gas prices over the last a couple of
weeks
but yet yes this is a global challenge
uh it's not just america as you all know
as you're laying out for me that's
dealing with inflation and this is why
the president has made this top of mind
and continues to make uh
his uh priority tackling inflation uh
his number one economic priority so
we're going to continue to do that and
focus on that remember there's an
inflation reduction act there's the
chips and and science and science act
that just passed uh there's a bipartisan
infrastructure legislation there's the
american rescue plan all of those things
in particular the american rescue plan
put us on a better footing
than most of uh than most of our global
partners
and so that's because of the work that
we have done the last 19 months okay
good steve thanks korean on the railroad
tentative agreement
it's been reported that the companies
have agreed to give the workers one
paid sick day the union's asked for 15
paid sick days why is that a deal the
worker should now accept as it goes to a
ratification
so as you know steve the government is
not a party to this deal and so we're
going to leave the specifics of the deal
to the two sides it's it's not something
that we're going to comment on but the
president today called it a win for the
country uh he suggested that the working
conditions will approve is he going to
get engaged to see to it that the
workers
ratify these these contracts so the way
that as as we look at the terms that was
agreed upon look rail workers will get
well-deserved pay increases that matters
that is important uh improved working
conditions that is important and peace
of mind around their health care costs
all of this is is hard earned so the
agreement is is indeed a victory uh for
railway companies as well who will be
able to retain and recruit more workers
for an industry that will continue to be
part of the backbone of american economy
for decades to come but we have to
remember what we averted here this would
have been devastating for economy
devastating for our supply chain so what
we saw uh
you know the last few hours in this uh
in this uh in this agreement uh is that
um you know we're we are it is good for
our economy and it is good for the
american people what did the president
say when he called into the talks last
night what what did he say that maybe
pushed it over the finish line so the
president message it was very clear we
must get a deal done
he pushed them once again to recognize
the harm that would hit families farmers
businesses and entire communities if
there was a shutdown he asked them to be
creative to be flexible
meet the other half
the others halfway as well and he
emphasized how significant the economic
impacts could be
i mean uh senator baldwin has said this
afternoon that the bill uh on same-sex
marriage is going to be pushed until
after the election and that she's
confident that it will pass
at that point signaling i suppose that
they think the republican votes will be
available after the election not before
whether the white house has any comment
on the timing of that bill so the
american people democrats republicans
alike
support marriage equality and so we see
that just across the board we believe
the senate should find should find
consensus just as the american people
have the president has been clear that
the right to marry whom you love is
non-negotiable and he's been steadfast
in his support for marriage equality
as well as the need for this legislation
given the supreme court's extreme
actions so this right is protected
everywhere so uh so you know as far as
the mechanics of this and how uh we move
this moves forward in the senate we
leave that to congress we leave that to
the leadership in congress there's
another another sort of very different
topic a couple of republicans wrote the
white house today seeking information
about the student debt
plan it's representative james comer and
virginia foxx they're concerned that
officials who worked on the plan
themselves may benefit from it under
seeking documentation about how many
white house aides would benefit uh from
the student debt cancellation do you
have any response to that i appreciate
you just got the letter tonight yeah i
haven't seen the letter so i certainly
am not going to respond to something i
haven't received but i i'll say if they
wonder something
people who
let's be very clear
here there's there's always so much
noise around the student let the student
loan debt relief let's be very clear on
what this is going to do this is going
to help
uh
peop americans and families who are
making americans who are making
um 90 of them are making less than 75
000 a year
that is going to give a huge relief to
so many of them who are going to now
maybe be able to put money down on a on
a house who are going to be maybe able
to start a family that's 90
is for people who make 75 000 and under
this is going to be a game changer and
uh and so that was the plan for that the
president had this is part of his
economic plan this is part of giving
people a little bit more of a breathing
room and this is what the student debt
relief uh will do and i'll leave it
there who worked on it were biased in
any way if they themselves had student
debt yeah i'm not going to respond to a
letter i haven't seen what i can tell
you is the facts and how this is going
to give some breathing room
to just imagine 90 of people who are
making less than 75 000 a year that
matters and it's going to be a game
changer
thanks green can you just first start
off by talking about the reports that
bill richardson is in moscow
trying to engage in the discussions to
bring
[Music]
so brittany greiner and paul wheeling
home and does the administration support
his efforts to do that so as as the
state department said yesterday they
spoke to this
private citizens attempting to broker a
deal
do not and cannot speak for the us
government
we we have warned private citizens not
to travel to russia
owing
russia to owing to the dangers that they
would face
and that the state department's russia
travel advisory remains at level four
and so what we have said and we have
been very clear and the state department
as i just mentioned uh spoke to this
yesterday is do not travel is very
concerned that he could actually
complicate the talks that the
administration is having or set them
back so
i'll say this uh
as it relates to um bill richardson so
we have been in contact with richardson
center
i'm just not going to comment on on the
governor's travels or the governor's
activities
but again we have been very clear about
american citizens traveling to russia
okay and i want to ask you um on the
topic of immigration the vice president
said to my colleague chuck todd over the
weekend the border is secure she also
caveated that to say we also have a
broken immigration system and talked
about the need to fix that
but does the white house stand by those
comments that the border is secure
what we stand by is that we are doing
everything that we can
uh to make sure that um
that we follow the process that's been
put forth that's why we have uh historic
funding to do just that to make sure
that
you know
to make sure that
to make sure that the folks that we
encounter at the border be removed uh or
expelled and again the facts are more
individuals encountered at the border
will be removed or expelled this year
than in any previous year
but that's the work that's that's we
that we have been doing is the border
secure i i'm just going to refer back to
the vice president we agree with her she
is saying that there's a lot of work to
do right she also said that in that very
statement we agree that the border is
secure but there is still more work to
be done i guess the you know the
question becomes how you can make that
argument when all dhs has said it's
bracing for these potentially two
million migrants to come which is you
know we'll say this rebuilding the
immigration system uh especially one
that was decimated under the previous
administration
won't happen overnight we're not going
to flip a switch and get that done
that's what i said at the beginning we
know that there's work to be done but
we're doing the work
to make sure that
that that we remove and expel
folks who are coming here
who are being encountered
at the border so
as as but as the actions of of listed
out show as i've listed out show we're
committed to getting it done and getting
and getting it done right we need to do
it in a humane way we need to do it in a
safe way
and as we have repeatedly said a
long-term solution can only come from a
comprehensive legislation that brings
lasting reform to a fundamentally broken
system we understand that and that's why
we continue to call on congress to also
act so we get it it's a it's a it's a
fundamental
uh long-term issue uh it is a broken
system uh but we are also doing the work
and you know i have to say the work that
what we're seeing republicans doing
uh elected officials using
using migrants as a pawn
is not the way to move forward on this
that's not how we're going to get this
done
if they want to help us then they should
help us by voting for
funding that will get the department of
homeland security funding that they need
to fix the system or by helping pass a
comprehensive immigration reform bill so
just one thing one more thing i want to
say according to npr
the migrants said a woman they identify
as a perla approached them and lured
them into boarding the plane saying they
would be flown to boston where they
could get expedited work papers the
migrant said she perla offered us help
help that never arrived that's not how
you treat people that is inhumane that's
not how we should be doing things there
is a process in place yes is there more
work to be done yes absolutely but there
is a process in place and that's what we
should be that's what these governors
should be doing
uh sure just one question on the
president's remarks in a little bit over
an hour um some have accused biden of
sort of fomenting the business in his
own right by labeling folks mega
republicans associating them with uh
with fascism i wonder if there's going
to be any effort in the president's
speech to sort of
reconcile that or to address that and is
there any concern that he as he tries to
draw a fin a line of demarcation between
democrats and republicans and ensuing
weeks that that'll contribute to
divisiveness so the president has been
very clear
that and he said this repeatedly i've
said this repeatedly not all republicans
are extreme mega republicans
many are not
he's worked with mainstream republicans
on a whole range of issues including
efforts to reduce violence and promote
public safety like kova 19 hates crimes
act and the bipartisan safety community
acts the most significant piece of
legislation to reduce gun violence in
nearly third years so the president is
hosting this event to highlight that the
vast majority of americans despite our
marriage of of differences are united in
opposition to hate-fueled violence so
this is a core american value that is
shared by people of all faiths
backgrounds and political parties and
he's been very clear about that
you
thank you i wanted to ask you about
pakistan last week u.s has announced
that it could be given
450 million dollars f-16 fighter jet
free sustainment program to pakistan and
if you remember in january 2018 the then
president had announced a blanket ban on
all kind of security assistance to
pakistan at that point and this had
remained so far has presented by lifted
that restrictions on pakistan so i want
to be very clear about this the proposed
f-16
sustainment package for pakistan is a
proposed sale and is consistent with
standard sustainment packages so i would
refer you to the state department for
more information on that particular
package but what was the president's
restrictions on in security assistance
to pakistan does that remain in place or
has that been lifted
so
i mean you were asking me about the f-16
so i i just i just laid that out for you
so i'll say this the strategic
partnership between the u.s and india is
grounded in our shared commitment uh to
the government to the advancement of
free and open indo-pacific region the
rule of law and the promotion of human
freedom and dignity we consult closely
with india on a regional developments
but i'm just not going to comment on any
diplomatic discussions i just laid out
what uh what the pack the f-16 package
is consistent with our standard stance
sustainment packages
as i just laid out any more on that
anymore
on our
on our diplomatic engagement i would
refer you to the state but i was not
able to explain yeah my question was
about u.s assistance to pakistan and
security related issues it was not about
india u.s relationship
oh okay
okay as you said about the f-16 yes f-16
but this is for the first time in three
and a half years that u.s has given any
security assistance to pakistan and this
was blocked in 2018 with tweet by then
president trump after that u.s has not
given any security assistance to
pakistan okay this is for the first time
after that so my question is have
president biden lifted that restrictions
on pakistan okay so um with that
specific question on security assistant
i would have to go back to the team and
get back to you on that i thought you
were asking about f-16 specifically and
that's the answer that i provided for
you on that nothing has changed on that
particular package but on the security
assistance i'm happy to check with the
team and get back clearly on uh pakistan
is going through a lot these days
because of floods what is u.s assessment
of the humanitarian situation
so we've provided a total of 53.1
million this year along to support
disaster resilience and flood response
in pakistan additionally centcom is
airlifting 41
41 200 kitchen seats
1500 rolls of plastic sheeting 35 000
plastic tarps and 8 700 shelter fixing
kits helping more than 300 000 people
with shelter and household needs and
usaid has has deployed a disaster
assistant response team to lead the u.s
government's continuing humanitarian
response efforts in pakistan and has
deployed technical experts from cdc to
assist with the public health impacts of
the flood
again since uh 2010 floods the united
states has supported preparedness
resilience and disaster risk reduction
efforts in pakistan improving the
ability of communities to withstand or
respond to disasters like this one i'm
going to move around i'm going to move
are we expecting from the summit today
things that are punishable things that
are not just policy but could move into
a law
so you're asking like what are the
deliverables essentially are the
deliverables concrete tangible
so a couple of things that we've
announced already is the new agency
actions to strengthen the federal
government's coordination and community
engagement to prevent respond to and
recover from hate fueled violence
federal agencies are also announcing new
steps to strengthen the resources
available to local schools law
enforcement agencies and cultural
institutions like museums and libraries
to prevent and respond to hate-fueled
violence there's a bipartisan former
white house officials they will launch
dignity dot
us us a citizen's initiative to address
hate fueled violence in america to
foster dialogue to communities across
the country and identify solutions to
address hate-filled violence there's a
new pluralists a cross-partisan group of
philanthropic and field leaders is
mobilizing one billion dollars in new
investments to increase support for
programs that build bridges among
americans to of of different backgrounds
to foster unity and also more than 140
mayors have signed a new bipartisan
compact to to
to compact to combat hate and extremism
uh committing to stand up against hate
violence and increase their support of
local initiatives and heal uh divides
and then there's there's also service
organizations led by interfaith america
the ymca and habit for habitat for
humanity are launching a nation of
bridge builders a new partnership that
will train ten thousand americans to be
bridge builders in their neighborhoods
and will host over one thousand bridge
building events in over three hundred
communities and one last that thing when
we think about technology uh communities
tech companies including youtube twitch
microsoft and meta are announcing new
actions their platforms are taking to
prevent hate fueled violence as well so
these this is going to be the
deliverables that are going to come out
of the summit this is about prevention
but is there an effort to work with
congress in this moment as you're having
this summit
to bring forth new laws uh more
punishments different punishments i
don't have anything new to preview at
this time that's happening with congress
uh clearly uh we believe these
deliverables these uh rundown of actions
that i just provided is a first step
to getting us into a place where we're
dealing with a real issue where we're
addressing hate-filled violence in
communities that we see across the
country then the last topic
on what you call this political stunt
with the asylum seekers
let's specifically get into the
locations
martha's vineyard
the naval observatory can you talk to
the issue of you said boston
it's an island that they sent
the asylum seekers to an island that um
is known to be
in some instances of democratic haven
former presidents former democratic
presidents vacation there own homes etc
could you speak to that as well as the
naval observatory
what i could say and i've been very
clear uh it is a political stunt
that's what we're seeing from governor
uh governors republican governors in in
particular and um
it is a cruel inhumane
way of treating uh people who are
fleeing communism
uh people who are who are uh and we're
not just talking about people we're
talking about children we're talking
about families
who are promised a home promised a job
put on a bus
and
you know driven to a place that they do
not know
and it is a cruel thing to do according
to local reports governor ron desantis
sent a hired videographer on the plane
to massachusetts
to order to capture footage of them
being dropped off remember there were
children on this plane so i cannot speak
to
anything outside of what we're seeing
right which is it is indeed a political
uh a political play it's cruel it is a
cruel uh way for elected officials the
people who have power uh the people who
are elected
by their constituencies
to behave in this way
and and we should call it out and other
republicans should call it out
republicans should be their colleagues
should be calling out
the cruel way that they are playing and
what they're doing uh with their cruel
political games and again these are
these are families that are including
children right
house democrats are currently making a
push to try and include free universal
school meals in the cr as a waiver for
this year is that something that the
president would support
i'm not going to speak to any any
specifics of what's going to be in or
out of the cr what we believe is that
we've been here before we were here just
last year
and we were able to get this done and we
believe congress can move forward just
like we were able to do uh to do to do
this last year look we're going to do
our job we're going to talk to
talk to members of congress on the hill
we're going to have conversations we're
going to make it very clear how
important it is
to make sure the cr gets passed but i'm
not going to get into specifics of what
we're going to accept or not accept yeah
on trains the deal with the railroads
came down to offering unpaid sick leave
is that a good deal for the workers and
what is the president going to do to
convince workers that they should vote
for that contract
so just to
just to step back for a second this is a
tentative deal and is actually a
standard part of the ratification
process the tentative agreement now goes
back to the unions for a vote and as
part of this tentative agreement the
parties have already agreed to a post
ratification cooling off period of
several weeks to make sure that if a
vote doesn't succeed for any reason
there is not an immediate rail shutdown
so this deal is on is right on track and
we expect the broad support for both the
labor and industry sides to continue i'm
not going to to speak to specific items
of the deal that's for them to decide
good care that's great um to go back to
bill richardson christian's question
guys the president spoke to bill
richardson around this trip to moscow i
don't have anything to preview all i can
tell you is that we have been in touch
with richardson center and you said that
russia should accept the significant
offer that the administration had made
for greiner and paul whelan and you had
said that the administration has
followed up on that offer repeatedly
what does that follow-up look like is
russia not responding or has russia
rejected that offer repeatedly i'm not
gonna get into uh private negotiations
uh at the podium uh just because of
security reasons and we want to make
sure that uh
you know we're having these
conversations in private so i'm not
going to
go into specifics but i can say the
russians should accept our offer we made
a a substantial offer and i'll leave it
there when you say followed up
repeatedly there's clearly it sounds
like there's a frustration that there's
something that's not coming back again
russians should accept our offer i'm not
going to go into any specifics anymore
on that conference
i wanted to clarify something you said
at the top so the administration got no
advance notice that this bus was heading
to the side of massachusetts avenue in
front of the vice president's residence
so i haven't spoken to the vice
president about this to or her team to
ask specifically if they were aware of
this uh of this this morning or last
night when it occurred so i can't speak
to that at this time
um because you mentioned at the top that
you weren't alerted but fox news was so
i just wanted to make sure i understood
you yeah that that is exactly what uh
what we have learned
um is there anything that the
administration oh i see what you're
asking me you're asking me
yes no we were not alerted the
department of health uh health uh the
department of homeland security was not
alerted we were not alerted of this i
thought you were asking me specifically
about the if they the vp's residents
i mean did you get any any advanced
notes from the state of florida no
my statement stands we were not alerted
um is there anything that the
administration can do to
prevent the governors of florida
or texas or any other state from sending
buses of migrants to the states of their
choice so
you know as far as
as far and some folks have asked us
about legal action that's going to go to
the department of justice can't speak to
that
what we have done
is
you know
we have the administration has been in
regular touch with the cities that have
to deal with this and fema regional
administrators have been meeting with
city officials on site to coordinate
available federal support from fema and
other federal agencies
and so that's how we have dealt with
this particular issue i think
for us how do we stop this we call this
out we call this out and we call it what
it is it is a political stunt that we're
seeing from these republican governors
that is what is happening and other
republicans should call this out as well
uh it is uh it is endangering people's
lives uh it is inhumane it is taking
away people's dignity not affording the
dignity uh that these uh these people
should be afforded and also we're
talking about children we're talking
about families and children that are
being left on the side you know the side
of the street side of uh of dc and in in
massachusetts and uh and it's it's
shameful and we should call this out so
you can highlight it but there really
aren't any political levers to prevent
it at this time again it's a political
stunt that republican governors are
using and uh and uh you know
the question is will republican uh
republicans uh call out uh their
colleagues for playing political a cruel
political game a cool political uh stunt
with migrants and families and children
who are fleeing communism that is what
they're fleeing they're fleeing
communism so okay let's see if we're
other republicans will call this out as
well
thank you karina um today for the first
time since russia's invasion of ukraine
vladimir putin met with xi jinping of
china he putin did say that he
understood that china had some quote
questions and concerns about the
invasion that he said he would address
them to xi uh she also
claire putin was a quote old friend so
does the white house have any early
reaction to this meeting between these
two leaders so we've made clear our
concerns um about the depth of china's
alignment
with and ties with with russia even as
russia prosecutes a war of aggression in
ukraine a brutal war a unprovoked war
that the kremlin started in ukraine
this meeting is an example of that
alignment i'm not going to go beyond
beyond those comments
do you think that americans believe that
the border is secure
what i can tell you is the record and
the process that we have been using
to make sure that we do our best to
secure the border
we do our best to make sure that we fix
a broken system that was left behind by
the last administration
and
and that's what we're we're going to
continue to do we understand it's not
like flipping a light switch
this does not happen overnight this is
an immigration system that is
fundamentally broken
and it's going to take some time but we
also need congress to take action we
need congress to act uh and to work with
us on uh on fixing this immigration
system and what we're seeing from
republican governors is not the way to
do it it is again and i'll keep saying
that it is inhumane it is cruel what
they're doing to children and to
families and if they want to work with
us on securing the border on fixing the
immigration system we're happy to do
that isn't there some risk though that
voters might feel like they're being
lied to when you were seeing images of
you know in el paso they've released a
thousand migrants on the street because
the processing centers are overwhelmed
there you know how is that humane how is
that safe as you guys talk about so
often when
it's it's overwhelming border cities and
they're asking the buying administration
to reimburse them for
charter buses to get them out of the
area because they're they're totally
overwhelmed so again it is a broken a
broken system the immigration system
and it was
it was decimated by the last
administration
that is a fact it was decimated by the
last administration
what the last administration wanted was
a border wall that was ineffective and
used a use of tax payers dollars
and
and
that's what we saw from the last
administration but just recently cbp
reported that that new wall along the
southwest border was reached over 3 000
times that new wall and between fiscal
year of 2019 and 2021
it's required
22.6 million in repairs that's what
we're trying to deal with with a
decimated a system that was certainly
not helped by the last administration
look we understand i'm not saying that
there's not more work to do we are
saying there's more work to do we are
saying that the system is broken but we
are saying that as well we have
we have done um
we have done a lot of work here to fix
this system and again more individuals
encountered at the border will be
removed or expelled this year than in
any previous year that those are the
facts you have a message for the
migrants though who are saying that the
border is open i mean today we talked to
a few who arrived in d.c
they said that the border is open we
know it's open because we come we enter
no problem
we haven't heard a message from the
administration in a few months telling
people not to come
um
we've heard you guys talking about
trying to make it a more orderly process
but you're not telling people not to so
department of homeland security
secretary mariokas has been very clear
he was
on tv recently talking about this
talking about the work that they do
and so i will leave it to the department
of homeland security to speak to that
specifically
but again this is a broken system and we
are we we want to see congress act we
want to see bipartisanship uh to fix the
immigration system we are fixing uh
trying to fix a system that was
decimated by the last administration and
again
we are calling for congress to take
action questioning inflation the
president dismissed the inflation report
and the stock market sell-off on his way
out of town yesterday and then he said
that test driving an electric car that
cost more than double the average
american's yearly salary made him feel
optimistic
is there
do you have a response to critics who
say this administration's out of touch
can you say that one more time the
president dismissed he dismissed the
inflation report he said he wasn't
worried about it we're talking about one
tenth of one percentage um and then he
said he wasn't concerned about the stock
market sell-off because he said the
stock market doesn't represent a broader
economy and then he went to detroit and
test drove a vehicle an electric car
that's just
out of price range for the average
american let me so i get your question
now so the president's number one
priority economic priority has been
lowering cost
for the american people you think about
the inflation reduction act which was
only passed by democrats republicans
refused to to get on board and pass it
in a bipartisan way it lowered costs for
uh uh for for medicare recipients capped
capped at two thousand a year when our
seniors are paying two thousand dollars
or more a month
and then you have republicans as well
who want to put
social security and they want to put
medicare on the chopping blocks so that
is the work that we are doing as
democrats we're trying to do everything
that we can to lower costs we're trying
to do everything that we can uh to make
sure that you know families keep their
social security unlike republicans and
families have medicare unlike what
republicans want to do which is take
that away look the question that the
president was asked about the day before
yesterday uh
which shows more progress that data the
cpi data which is what he was he was
speaking to shows more progress in
bringing global inflation down in the
u.s economy overall
prices have been essentially flat in our
country these last two months that is
welcome news for american families but
no doubt no doubt we have more work to
do and we understand that and so we are
seeing some encouraging sign including
in
inventories up
used vehicle prices down and a cooling
housing market which is important it
will take more time and resolve to bring
inflation down which is why again we
pass the inflation reduction act we
meaning democrats not republicans to
lower cost of health care to lower costs
of prescription drugs to lower cost of
energy and you know the president's
economic plan is creating good jobs and
bringing manufacturing back uh to
america we've seen more than six hundred
thousand manufacturing jobs return to
the us in the in the last 19 months of
this administration i'm going to move on
um you mentioned um that you on
immigration that you would like to see
you know congress act has a white house
at all engaged with you know um
lawmakers on capitol hill on this has
there been any sort of updated timeline
on kind of when you want to see any
action on this so we would like to see
an action as soon as possible so the
president proposed a comprehensive
immigration reform package on his first
day
in office and he continues to call on
congress as you just heard me say to get
to get uh this to his desk for him to
sign so
again congressional republicans should
stop blocking bills to build a set safe
orderly humane immigration system it is
not there is not a there is not action
from them to actually deal with this
issue that we're seeing uh with the
immigration system so the team here at
the white house is in regular touch with
congress as you're asking me on a number
of priorities including immigration
reform and we will continue to again
urge congress to get that bill to his
desk and another question um reuters is
reporting that um you know the vita
administration is
kind of asking mexico to
accept more migrants from cuba and
nicaragua
venezuela under title 42 is this
something that you know the
administration is asking for um you know
are there concerns that there's an
increase of um
you know individuals coming from those
countries so i'll say this uh any
diplomatic negotiations or conversations
i would refer you to the state
department on that specific question but
on more broadly uh on the matter of
title 42 our views have been very clear
title 42 is a public health authority it
is not an immigration authority and that
authorities rest with the cdc as you've
heard us say many times a court order
a court ordered us to continue enforcing
the cdc's title 42 authority and we will
continue to comply with the quarters uh
for as long as it remains uh in effect
but anything with negotiations with any
of the countries i would refer you to
the state department thanks career
okay let me take let me take two more oh
correct let me just i'm trying to call
them folks
on south africa can i do a quick
follow-up on the upcoming summer go
ahead south africa okay thank you you
said at the top that during their
bilateral meeting tomorrow with
president ramaphosa of south africa do
we discuss climate crisis investment
and other global issues with that
include the
russia war in ukraine we know that
russia was one of the african countries
that didn't go that refused to be drive
into the proxy war between the u.s and
russia
i don't have any more specific to what i
just laid out about the issues that they
would be talking about we will certainly
share more in our readout as we normally
do when there's a a a bilat but i don't
have more to share outside of that is
the president aware that every time he
received
a an african head of state african
journalists who cover the white house
are not allowed like i'm not allowed to
be there tomorrow is there something
that's still that's it well are you okay
we did to have an african job
an african president being received by
president biden and the african who
covered the white house let me let me
let me check into that because that is
uh that is a serious claim and we take
those claims very seriously uh obviously
and so uh let me check into that uh that
is not something that i'm aware of my
question actually is who who makes the
decision who tells the white house not
to allow us when we sense well you're
saying again i i need to check in on on
what you're stating here that is a
serious uh statement that you're making
so before i go any further i need to
just check in on that
i'm happy i'm always happy to talk to
anyone after the briefing in my office
or make us make a you know a scheduled
appointment to have this conversation
but again what you're saying is a is a
you know a strong accusation if you will
and i just need to check in on that
before before before i move further i
need to check in on that i will not be
allowed to be there tomorrow so it's a
claim that's been established and that
was the same thing that happened when
saki was here with the president of
kenya and and you understand the
frustration of people like me who come
everywhere
i understand i wholeheartedly understand
your frustration but before i can speak
to this i need to actually check in on
it so that i can give you
uh a a fulsome answer so let me check in
on this and we can talk about it
all right
thank you career if i could please
quickly update on the upcoming summit
but first i'd like to extend you a happy
uh hispanic heritage month as the son of
a latino immigrant so well thank you
my question is very straightforward uh
you just mentioned recently about the
work that republicans have done together
with the president in
combating hate and my question is if you
can share with us some of the prominent
republicans who are planning to be
participating in this upcoming summit so
if you see the agenda
you'll see we have bipartisan group of
folks participating today
we again we really believe
that the vast majority of americans
including republicans including
democrats including independents are
united against hate fueled violence this
is a core american value that is shared
by people of all faiths and backgrounds
and political parties so this event is
featuring people of diverse backgrounds
ideologies as well as bipartisan group
of elected officials and leaders who
share the view that we all have a role
to play in bridging the divides in our
communities and working to eradicate the
hate-filled violence that tears apart
communities and hurts our democracy
again
if you take a look at the agenda you
will see the bipartisanship there i'll
see you guys tomorrow thank you
everybody